I'm curious because I saw you you spoke
about what skip tweeted uh obviously
Demar Hamlin is uh going through it uh
that was a very scary situation as a pro
athlete yeah obviously you know there's
there's risk in football you played
football yeah
um
but you know it was definitely a scary
situation
um and then the interaction between
Shannon and Skip on TV today was pretty
yeah it was it was hard to watch I just
it it it's disheartening because you
know as a as a player I used to really
like skip but I I thought his take
sometimes were you know would toe the
line but he was good like he knew what
he was talking about but I just feel
like I don't know I think as maybe as
his celebrity is growing he is his his
entitlement and his
lack of respect for players his co-host
has just kind of continued just to climb
and I felt though although he said some
other stuff in his tweets like
it was just an insensitive and an
untimely thing to
tweet out for the world to see at that
time when this man is literally his
heart is beating stop beating twice on
the field you know what I mean and
but skip is smart you know so when skip
said you know how can they think about
canceling or whatever exact words were
this is so meaningful but then at the
end he knows like yeah this is a little
spicy so let me put you know everything
seems so irrelevant right now though
like he knew what he was doing like you
just like again wrong time wrong place
for the Tweet but I think like I said
it's been building up like the way he
disrespects Shannon today this morning
but like two weeks a couple of weeks ago
yeah a couple of weeks ago it was bad it
was bad and I I made a post today
talking about like I've had and I'm not
gonna give up no names but I've had to
put out two fires of people currently in
the NBA
they won the whoops Skip's ass
and I had to connect dots to to to get
you know these kind of phone calls
Hannah because like I said it's just
there again there's a line there's and
and to me he's and again he will you
know his he has a long line of you know
respectable work in this business but
again I just feel like of late it's been
crazy but it's just like people are
tired of that you know I mean like at
the end of these are men like you're
talking to men that that that raise
their children you know what I mean and
and have to you know walk around in
public with you just like blatantly
disrespect like motherfucker's not
playing that no more I think too like
when you know I think sometimes this
happens with Stephen A because like
obviously skip is the biggest
personality on that channel as as by the
way I tweeted this the other day I think
it was Christmas
and Stephen A Smith was on TV all
[ __ ] day
I was like this is the hardest work how
much money could ESPN pay with this guy
because you know he's he's he's he's
getting I'm I'm happy for Steve no he's
killing him he's killing it and I
understand but but I'm from a standpoint
like I understand skip like skip has
that lane so it's almost like a one-up
type how can I keep how can I keep on
having my name in everyone's mouth and
being right you know what I mean so it's
just like but I just feel like
lately he's been in and you've seen
times where just like Shannon I mean I
got a lot of respect for Shannon sharp I
mean there's a lot of times where you
can see he's taking deep breaths and
he's trying to calm down from having to
ring this dude's neck on on live TV and
you would and and you know there's times
where I really do feel like that they
have some genuine love for each other no
I I yeah they definitely do Shannon had
a lot of because we had him on the show
not to cut you off but Shannon has a lot
like paid a lot of love and respect to
to skip making that show happen and how
skip City wouldn't work with no one so
there's a lot of love there like he's
openly said that but I think of late
like to me it's that that entitled
arrogance that he he he he throws out
there in in the one a few weeks ago when
he did Tony put his glasses back on I'm
just like yeah no that was [ __ ] crazy
you out of your mind yeah you ever seen
a Rottweiler on a Chihuahua yeah like
nobody talks like you shouldn't talk to
anybody like that let alone someone you
have loving oh man that like that's
that's that's your true feelings you
know what I mean that's supposed to be
your man right there and and to let it
happen on TV like it just to me it that
should Rick's entitlement I wonder how
long that's gonna I always I after I saw
it today I was like this can't last much
longer I mean the same thing I put the
same thing out there I'm just like you
know unfortunately this show I feel like
is going to come to an end because like
there's only so much Shannon's going to
take you know what I mean and Skip is
who he is and they're and it sucks
because they're really good they're
great together really good shot it's
they're better than skipping Stephen A
no to me they're they're name it name it
because remember when remember when it
was Steven and Skip and everybody was
like what's gonna happen Skip's leaving
the fox I'll take Shannon over and and
skip over over the old first take any
day man I mean I I like I like what
Stephen A Smith does and you know
obviously I'm at ESPN so I got a lot of
love no no but but just just straight if
I'm talking like straight like if I'm uh
them two right there together they're
Dynamic it's been gold yeah you know for
a while but like I said I just I think
he obviously Shannon sees it the world
sees it like skip is just really really
feeling himself on on on a disrespectful
tip of late engines I just don't think
people are going to continue to to put
up with that so